former presidents and world leaders are
remembering Senator John McCain a
military hero who became a political
giant McCain died of brain cancer at his
Arizona home Saturday funeral services
will be held in Phoenix Washington DC
and Annapolis Maryland the flag at our
nation's capitol is flying at half-staff
this morning to honor McCain his wife
Cindy wrote on Twitter that her heart is
broken and that her husband quote passed
the way he lived on his own terms
Nancy Court has covered the Senators
career for the past decade she's in
Phoenix Nancy good morning good morning
and I want to show you the front page
Anthony of the Arizona Republic
it says political giant Arizona legend
that legend will be lying in state here
at the Arizona State Capitol building
and at the US Capitol in Washington DC
this week part of a hero's send-off for
a man who served this state for 36 years
and served his country in war it's tough
I'm gonna miss him
McCain's fellow Arizona Senator Jeff
Flake got to say goodbye in person this
weekend it's it's tough to imagine a
Senate without him it's tough to imagine
politics without John McCain the
six-term senator and father of seven was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
brain cancer thirteen months ago and had
time to plan his own funeral first a
memorial service here in Phoenix former
Vice President Joe Biden has been asked
to speak
oh there's John as has McCain's first
congressional chief of staff grant woods
what was he like as a novice politician
he knew every issue backwards and
forwards and loved to talk about him the
reason he won is because he knocked on
everybody's door in that district
multiple times former President Barack
Obama said he and McCain shared a
fidelity to something higher and former
President George W Bush described McCain
as a patriot of the highest order both
men have been invited to eulogize McCain
on Saturday in Washington
president Trump expressed deepest
sympathies for McCain's family this
weekend but did not pay tribute to the
senator
the two men often clashed he's a war
hero because he was captured I like
people that weren't captured okay
the funny part of it is didn't buy the
John McCain at all he could care less
and and that's just because okay I mean
I've lived a pretty full life here I'm
gonna do what I think is right later
this week McCain will lie in state at
the US Capitol his longtime colleagues
remembering their friend he was widely
respected but he knew what the goal was
the goal was to make this a better
nation Arizona Governor Doug Ducey says
that out of respect for the McCain
family he will not be naming a successor
to John McCain in the US Senate until
after McCain is laid to rest next
weekend and he has chosen to be buried
gale at his beloved US Naval Academy
where he will find his final resting
place near the grave of a longtime
friend so appropriate such a class act
Thank You Nancy so much